he's Greg Anthony back here on the show
how are you Greg I'm doing great man I'm
doing great
is uh let's let's just jump right into
it here the whole question is is which
which one of the stars I know if you
were able to hear the recounting of
which one of the ringless stars whose
career you'd rather have if you read
them the poll question one more time
here Chris yeah running down Charles
Barkley Patrick Ewing Karl Malone Steve
Nash John Stockton what do you think
Greg does that include the totality of
their careers post basketball no I think
it's just them basketball good question
Greg good question well no that might
change it I would probably I probably
still go barking why was that then I
think he's headless I think Malone has
had an incredible career I think those
are the two guys that are the of the
floor the best players and I think you
know those two guys were in the
conversation his best player and the
league the other two weren't and that's
no slide on they were obviously
tremendous players but also I probably
would have liked playing and Phoenix and
Houston because they got great golf nice
and winner yeah
jelly also yeah I would have had a
chance to play with dr. J which would
have been pretty cool Moses Malone okay
so that's key you got a factor all that
in you got a factor all yeah and I think
he was a more marketable star of all
four and so I would probably go that
route you know obviously he got to play
in the finals and win it but he didn't
make it so I would probably go with the
Chester okay very good
what'd you think of the Charles Shaq
back and forth on on TNT last no all
great I loved it I loved it I was
retweeting it this morning
and you know our any of it is in a weird
way they both kind of for right you know
I don't know that you know I'm not as
concerned with the rose and not playing
in that fourth quarter because we've
seen that happening on many occasions
with great players because it wasn't
going well and the group out they put
out there ends up getting the job done
all you got to do is go back a few years
ago with Chris Paul on the Clippers for
playing Houston James Harden got benched
mm-hmm in the closeout game when it was
3-1 he didn't play in that fourth
quarter they were down
I don't know 16 17 they come back they
win that game they go on to win the
series so you know that stuff happens
Scottie Pippen got benched I would call
when we played him when I was with the
Knicks
well he wouldn't cut was that Jamie
didn't come off the bench Greg is that
the game where he refused to come back
off the bench yeah exactly what were you
guys thinking about because obviously
Rodney hood is a similar case although
it was a blowout he wouldn't go in the
game yeah you know it's not as big a
deal as it will be made out to be in the
world we live in the day because that
stuff actually happens a lot and it's
more about you being a professional and
owning up to it
apologize before what you did the coach
ain't got to take that personal the kids
you know worldment turned upside down
comes in a new situation has it gone
well struggling with his confidence you
know and from what I understand it
wasn't malicious he just basically said
hey once you just let the other guys
play now again I don't know verbatim but
that's what I was told it's a non-issue
you know and in some ways this might
help him in terms of trying to get his
feel I mean this stuff people don't
understand how hard it is to go from one
team to another I remember Derek Harper
did that he came from the Mavericks to
the mix and when I tell you he was a
shell of himself for about two months I
mean he had no confidence and this the
guy had been a multiple all-star and had
played on one of the best teams in the
league with the Mavericks with Rolando
Blackmon and it just took him a while to
kind of get comfortable but once he did
he just took off
and got back to being a player that he
had been over the course of his career
so it could be a similar dynamic like
it's just tough
when you're coming into a new situation
new role new terminology new city new
expectations all that stuff and it does
affect different people differently and
I you know I feel karate hood I think
eventually he's going to figure out who
he is within that environment and
hopefully things work out TNT and VA TVs
Greg Anthony here in the Rich Eisen show
is Chris Paul in a Hall of Famer that's
a no-brainer you know burst Hall of Fame
before the season started he doesn't
have to win a rim doesn't have to get to
the finals no think about the week this
whole narrative about Championships or
bust
defining who you are the Tracy McGrady
to get to the finals I don't think so
McGrady won a first-round playoff series
the grant he'll get to the finals no
like that better that doesn't define the
player but it really doesn't I mean
Chris Paul's career is incredible you
know when you look at what he's done as
a basketball player how many times he's
been an all-star how many times he's
been all in BA how many times he's been
all-nba defense and he's a lock to be a
whole thing he was a lock to be in the
Hall of Fame before this season started
so yeah that's a that's a no-brainer now
that's actually a neat you okay so then
what about this upcoming series here
Greg break it down for me warriors
raucous when they finally get around to
playing on Monday yeah I think this will
be the first time that Golden State
first of all it's first time in this run
where they won't have home court right
they have had home court in every series
they played I picked the last four years
that's going to be interesting in and of
itself secondly I do think that Houston
is built to play with Golden State they
are incredibly good defensively along
the perimeter they've got great rent
protection they got a guy that can
finish in traffic
in terms of capella and they've got two
true superstars
to combat what what's going to say that
now what that means to me is the series
could become it could be an epic series
like this could be a seven-game you know
incredible series the kind that you
dream up you know that you talk about
clearly the two best teams in the
regular season
although Toronto had a game lead on
Golden State let's remember the Golden
State has dealt with all kinds of
injuries all year and the mental fatigue
of having you know in the process of
trying to go to 14 seconds or five so I
just think it's going to be incredible
and you know James Harden you know
didn't have his best game but I guess he
was under the weather in Game five of
that series Chris Paul as you guys saw
unbelievable you see Golden State's
starting to look like a team we thought
they'd be all season draymond Green has
been incredible in this postseason Steph
Curry healthy you know Durant is Durant
and with clay the only question for me
with Golden State is and you saw it a
little bit in the New Orleans series the
bench hasn't been as good as the
championship caliber the championship
team that had in the past and how
sneaker manipulations lineup may it may
ultimately determine who interesting
because he put on Iguodala and that
starting lineup and the team functioned
well but they were good enough to beat
New Orleans I don't know if they're
gonna be good enough to beat Houston
without contributions from their bench
I do think this series will challenge
them in ways they haven't been
challenged in the Western Conference and
I'm excited to see it you know it's been
building to this all year they've been
like I said the two best teams there's a
two best overall teams you look at their
offensive the defensive numbers and you
know they feature four of the top you
could argue 1012 players in the league
and if you throw you start talking about
dream on and clay you could argue for
the top 20 players are six of the top 20
so this series
going to have everything you could want
as a basketball fan or a casual fan and
I'm excited to see the chess match
between D'Antoni and speaker and like I
said if those stars can all deliver I
think there's gonna be more pressure on
Houston particularly what the first two
games being at home and how they come
out and play but but this one man I
don't recall ever being this excited
about a conference final in the last
honestly it's been over ten years for
sure so so I'm really looking forward to
seeing how seeing how these two teams
match up and the Warriors Rockets who
takes it what do you think I mean the
Warriors it really is but I'm gonna go
out on a limb and take the Rockets in
this one because of the home court I do
think it doesn't always play a role but
if the teams are pretty evenly matched I
give them a slight edge those they got
two guys and Harden and Paul who listen
you know and the eyes of others will
validate their careers if they can win
this serie and I think it will be a
legacy to finding one and I'm going to
give them a slight edge which I still
I'm not going to be surprised in the
least that if Golden State wins this
thing cuz they really I don't know that
we've ever seen a construct of talent
that meshed so seamlessly as the one we
see and go and stay right now those guys
complement each other from an IT
standpoint ability to play with and
without the basketball on both ends as
well as any team I've ever seen and
really the reason I give the Rockets a
little nod is because for them to try to
go to a four consecutive finals man that
is going to be something to really take
in and see so I'm excited I'm going out
on the lemon comes in the rockets but I
like I said I got a head because I'm not
going to be surprised at all if Golden
State walk loose last one for you Gregg
in the minute I have left for you it was
the 24th anniversary of the Reggie
Miller Spike Lee
moment in Madison Garden know about
here's here's why I go there Greg it
would not have happened had the fowl
been called where you got shoved down
right Greg you got shoved out of the leg
right I read you not talking about this
all time I hundred percent agreement
with you there's no doubt about it and
i'm just still painful to think about
well what does Reggie simply what is
Reggie say wha what does Reggie say when
you say I mean if there was a lack let's
put it this way if the NBA had a last
two-minute report then right we would
have seen that right Greg yeah and you
know what would have happened after they
put the report out not a damn thing it's
one of the biggest most useless piece of
information ever so what that Nate what
I don't change the call okay you know
like it's not going to change the call
so what happened happened and and and
whether they missed or do not look I
can't tell you I've never been a game in
the NBA where I didn't have the
officials tell me we've missed the call
and I tell young players all the times
they listen don't expect officials would
be perfect because you're not perfect
you turn it over you miss shots you
commit silly fouls you make you know you
make mistakes over the course of a game
that's just par for the course you just
gotta forget move on Greg I've have to
move on to thanks for the call
appreciate it
all right guys that's Greg Anthony the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience